[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILIP: Hello, everyone.
Welcome back to the
Flutter Boring Show.
I'm here.
My name is Phillip.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Flutter team.
And with me is Will.
Will is an engineer on
the Material Design team.
Will, hi.
WILL: Great to be here, Filip.
Thank you.
FILIP: Yeah.
So I was always
going to ask you,
what does an engineer do on
the Material Design team?
WILL: Well, we have
different teams
set up for all the
different platforms--
iOS, Android, web,
and now Flutter.
And we work on what we call
the material components, which
are, in the case of Flutter,
the widgets and the material
library, the things that
implement material design
and material theming.
And we build them, or
maintain them, or collaborate
with the teams that
are building them,
in order to keep
them up to date,
and try to make them
consistent across all
the different platforms.
FILIP: All right.
So a lot of the widgets that
we're using in an app like this
are coming from you.
WILL: Well, I mean, I can't
take all the credit myself.
But yeah, my team is
definitely always helping
to make sure that
they're up to date.
And if we know anything
is around the corner,
then Flutter can get
it at the same time
as the other platforms,
which is great.
FILIP: So we were thinking--
OK, so we have our Hacker News
app, which by the way, amazing.
WILL: I saw it.
I love it.
It's great.
FILIP: So would do you think
that it's like the top app
that you've ever seen,
in terms of design?
WILL: Well, you're starting
with Material Components.
So you're already on the way.
That's good.
I think if we were to
critique the look, the style
at the moment, it's
a little out of date,
or a little default or plain.
There's probably
some things that we
could do with material
theming and with styling
in order to make it fresher.
FILIP: OK, all right.
So let's do just that.
So just for people who are
completely new to the show,
these is our Hacker
News Reader app, which
is very simple and functional.
Do you have-- this is
actually-- since last episode,
this is actually talking to
the Hacker News API proper.
So these are new things
coming from Hacker News.
WILL: No, that's great.
FILIP: You get the news
stories, the top stories,
and you can open this.
And I'm not going to do
that, because I don't
know what these articles are.
But you can open it
in your web browser.
And that's basically it.
We're not going
to make anything--
no new features, I think.
We'll just keep this with
this kind of functionality,
maybe unless you hate
this, we could just
keep this opening like this.
WILL: Oh, yeah, no.
I think that's great.
FILIP: And then--
but yeah, maybe we
can mix it even nicer-looking.
WILL: So where I start--
you know, I'm not a designer.
I am an engineer.
But I know that there
are a lot of resources
out there on our website, on
material.io, for both designers
and developers to have
inspiration and tools in order
to help with design.
So when I need to redo
something on my own,
that's where I start in
order to get some inspiration
and some existing
designs that designers
have spent their time.
FILIP: So you're
saying material--
WILL: --.io.
Yeah.
FILIP: So what do you do here?
WILL: So if I was just coming
in to get documentation
about any of the tools I was
using, I'd go to Develop.
But since today we're
worrying about design,
I'd click on Design.
FILIP: This is slow today.
OK.
Is it just me?
WILL: So this is
essentially what
we call the material
guidelines, which
is the breadth of
knowledge and opinion
that we've put together with
research over the years that
keeps apps looking consistent,
and usable, and beautiful.
And one of the things
we've done recently
is put, under Material Studies,
some hypothetical apps that
look like something
somebody would find
from another
company, not Google,
so that you can
get an idea of what
options are out there for
styling and theming your apps.
FILIP: Nice.
So OK, so let's go with Basil.
And then you can tell
us-- ah, that's nice.
All right, so this
is for people who
don't know where to start
with material design.
And this will give them
some kind of a framework.
WILL: Yeah, so this
is taking all things
that we have in the
guidelines, and actually
putting them to
use in one place.
And kind of showing you step by
step all the different values
that got us there.
So if you down to Color,
you'll see the palette.
There it is.
Keep going down.
This is the color scheme that
the designer came up with.
This is a food app.
So it's inspired by
pesto, literally.
And then if you keep
going down to typography,
you can see the
different typefaces
that were chosen for this.
And there's iconography, and
motion, and other cool things
there.
And so we have this for
several different apps.
FILIP: Right.
Which of those apps--
so this looks like 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7 different apps.
Which one is most similar
to this, do you think?
WILL: I think one of the ones
that might be very similar
is Fortnightly.
It's a newspaper app.
So a very similar idea--
serving content, lots of text,
text being very important.
And also kind of getting out
of the way of the content
since there's so much.
When you have a lot
of text on the screen,
that's work for
the eye, and kind
of work for the person who's
using it to try to consume.
So this puts that in the
front, and spends time
on the information
architecture and space
around the text as
necessary, to make it
more readable and consumable.
So that's a good one.
Another one that might
be good is Reply.
FILIP: Reply.
WILL: This one's an
email or message creator.
But obviously it's not
about the functionality.
It's about, does this show
the same similar things,
which is text.
Again, we're showing
text, and this is text.
So this kind of comes at
it from a text-heavy angle.
And then if we wanted to get
really wacky for some reason,
probably the most
fun one is Owl.
FILIP: Yeah, if you
can't remember Owl, yeah.
WILL: This one's got
the bright colors.
This one is a study in
super-bold design choices,
and then also what I call scoped
theming, where different--
you can see here on the screen
that the personalized flow is
based on yellow, the browse
flow is based on blue,
the learn flow is based on red,
which is just this cool idea
that if you have a
multi-featured app that
does several different
things, maybe you
can use theming to help people
have a better ground to where
they are, based on a context.
FILIP: I like it.
Yeah, so what do you think
about Flutter Hacker News?
Do we want to do
something wacky, or more
like the Fortnightly?
WILL: Well, if we started with
Fortnightly, we could always--
we can try more than one.
I mean, that's the great
thing about Flutter
is it moves so fast.
FILIP: Right.
WILL: You can
check your choices.
FILIP: So, OK.
Let's get-- so
where do we start?
Where do we start here?
So basically this is the
whole code of the app,
because the rest is
just different classes,
like serializers
and stuff like this.
So we can just start
here, and I guess
play with this theme data.
WILL: Exactly.
So every material app that takes
theme data in the theme field.
And in there, that's where
you can set all your things
having to do with
your color scheme
and with the text theme
that you will have,
button theme, which is of
course how your buttons will
be styled.
So yeah, if we take a look
at theme data and its fields,
see how many that was?
There was a lot there.
We can start changing some of
the values that we see on--
any from the study side.
Yeah.
It might be good
to start with Owl,
because then we'll
really be able to see
the changes quickly.
So you can get some hex values
down in the Color section.
FILIP: Ah, all right.
So well, I mean, we kind of
have to work around, I think,
the Hacker News orange.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
WILL: Well--
FILIP: [INAUDIBLE] That's OK.
Let's do what the
designers [INAUDIBLE]
WILL: They'll never know.
[CHUCKLING]
FILIP: So primary swatch?
WILL: Yeah, the
primary swatch is
a color that's then
also applied sometimes
through darker use of it.
So that's how we get
that thing in the app
bar where the status bar is
darker that's beneath it.
FILIP: So--
WILL: So, what do you think?
The yellow section, the red
section, or the blue section
would be a good
one to start with?
FILIP: I like the yellow.
WILL: Let's start with yellow.
FILIP: Yeah?
So I just say this--
this guy, FF--
[INAUDIBLE]
WILL: For the
swatch, you might not
be able to put hex
value in there.
I believe you have to
send in a material color
type or something like
that, which is actually
a collection of colors.
So it would probably
be better just
to get rid of primary
swatch, and start
with the primary color.
FILIP: Primary color is--
and I don't know.
Is there a copyable--
WILL: No.
It just appeared to you.
So FFDE03.
FILIP: FFDE03.
WILL: And then FF
again for the alpha.
FILIP: OK, yeah.
WILL: [INAUDIBLE] was
the alpha at the start.
Well, we'll find out.
Ah, alpha must be at the start.
FILIP: Right.
That's also good, by the way.
WILL: There we go.
FILIP: Nice.
WILL: Yellow.
FILIP: So-- oh, I thought--
so do we want to
have it like this,
or like they have it
at the background?
Everything is yellow like this.
WILL: Ah, yeah,
so that would be--
I forget which color is the
background for a scaffold.
Does this list view have
any color set on it,
or is this just the default?
FILIP: Yeah, it's the
default. So can we
do like a background color?
WILL: We'll try
background color.
FILIP: And do,
since I have this--
WILL: No, that's not it.
FILIP: Let me see
if [INAUDIBLE] do
we have color here somewhere?
WILL: Let's look
in the theme data,
and see if it's obvious from
the names of the fields.
There's a lot of them.
There we go.
That might be the
one right there,
scaffold background color.
FILIP: OK, so--
WILL: All right.
FILIP: All right.
WILL: Already starting
to look more like Owl.
FILIP: Yeah.
WILL: It's definitely more Owly.
FILIP: Uh huh.
So what do we do with the top?
WILL: So let's see if
there's any inspiration back
in the study
[INAUDIBLE] It doesn't
look like they use an app
bar in that part of the app.
FILIP: We also don't need to.
It doesn't do anything
really important.
WILL: What's that
Why button for?
FILIP: That's not a button.
That's just an
icon that flashes.
That was one of our things.
It flashes when you load.
But nobody notices, so I
think we can get rid of it.
WILL: Yeah.
I mean, so one of
the things that I've
seen in a lot of
people do when they
don't want a very defined
app bar is to color the app
bar the same color
as the background,
and remove its elevation,
so that you still
get the functionality of an app
bar, which is having the title,
without having to have
it be so pronounced.
FILIP: So that would
be a primary color
with the same color.
So now just for the sake of--
so this would be our const
primaryColor is this.
WILL: Always a good
idea-- best practice.
FILIP: Maybe static.
And then, so that's primayColor,
and that's a primaryColor.
And then we delete this.
[MAKING PERCUSSIVE SOUND EFFECT
WITH MOUTH]
OK.
WILL: Awesome.
FILIP: And then
you're saying app bar
now doesn't have elevation--
0.
Ooh.
[MAKING PERCUSSIVE SOUND EFFECT
WITH MOUTH]
Interesting.
WILL: So that's a very
iOS paradigm, the idea
of not having a shadow.
FILIP: Right.
WILL: Yeah.
FILIP: Now I want to have it
left-aligned with the rest.
[INAUDIBLE]
WILL: Well, if we get
rid of the leading, what
will happen to the title?
It will move over?
Because you said
we don't need it.
FILIP: Yeah.
WILL: Close.
That would drive
me insane, though.
FILIP: I mean, let's not maybe--
I don't know.
WILL: Well, IRL--
FILIP: Do we really
want that, though?
WILL: Oh, no.
I think on Owl, they,
instead of having an app bar,
have a really cool title
with an image at the top.
It's their logo lockup,
essentially, at the top.
FILIP: Yeah, I saw that.
So this, right.
So we could just-- hm, I
still want to have it aligned.
Is it just me, or--
WILL: No, it's not just you.
FILIP: OK, so can we
left-align it just by--
WILL: Maybe.
So what's going on
inside the app bar
is probably harder
to change than what's
going on inside your list view.
Do have padding going on
inside of these widgets?
FILIP: Yeah, I think
all is default.
So we have a list view
build item that's-- oh,
that is padding.
WILL: I bet it's 8.
FILIP: OK, so-- yeah.
No?
WILL: No.
FILIP: No.
6?
WILL: 4.
FILIP: 4?
WILL: That's it.
FILIP: All right.
WILL: And then the way
you can double-check
this is with the inspector.
FILIP: Tell me.
WILL: Because if you
highlight either of those,
a line will draw
around it, and then
that will give your
eye an easier way
to focus down to see if that
line, in your imagination,
kind of goes down to the next--
FILIP: Right, right.
So, I haven't used the
inspector in a little while.
WILL: See that one that kind
of looks like the X-Men logo?
FILIP: Right.
WILL: Yeah, click
that, and then you
can click into any of the things
on the screen in the simulator.
And then there--
FILIP: No, this is not on an
emulator, that's the thing.
There's no--
WILL: Oh, it's over here?
FILIP: Yeah.
Ah, OK, yeah.
WILL: Hey, you just
used your finger.
[CHUCKLING]
That's also free.
FILIP: OK, so is this
really just four pixels?
WILL: Obviously it's four
pixels on top of some default.
FILIP: Right.
WILL: Because if we--
so we click outside.
It's just a little bit hard
because my finger is so chunky.
Oh, sorry.
No, I have to hit
the thing again.
OK, so let me do that.
Yeah.
No.
FILIP: Ah.
WILL: OK, so it's
wrapped in your padding.
FILIP: All right.
WILL: See, so that's
not your padding.
That must be a padding that you
get for free from what's the--
FILIP: Safe area.
WILL: Safe area.
Yeah, all right.
Which is great, because
that means you can trust it.
FILIP: Right.
Good, that's awesome.
So OK, so we have this.
I already like this.
Let's not do that now.
So are we gonna
maybe make this--
maybe the list style
should be a little more--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILL: I thought it
was good on top.
FILIP: Yeah.
On top?
Yeah, OK.
WILL: Yeah, the vertical
padding was good.
FILIP: Right.
WILL: So you can do that--
FILIP: So, symmetric?
WILL: Yeah.
FILIP: OK, so the
horizontal is 4,
and vertical is [INAUDIBLE] 16.
WILL: It was 16.
FILIP: Now I think it
might be even less, like 8.
What do you think?
WILL: 12.
We do things in fours.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
WILL: That feels
right for some reason.
FILIP: Yeah, all right.
I trust you.
WILL: And that's
one of the lessons
we got from
Fortnightly and Reply,
is giving space to the words.
Because one of the
things that we've learned
is that if you read a
pictographic text, like most
Chinese glyph
sets, and Japanese,
you can take much
denser text and still
be able to comprehend
it quickly.
But we, being based
on Latin characters,
end up reading these things
out phonetically in our heads.
So if too much is
going on, then we
can't follow the
line with our eyes
in order to read it out loud.
So that's why we prefer--
speaking English-- more
space around these words.
But if you were doing
this in Chinese,
you could go ahead and
bring that all the way in,
and try to put as
many characters
as you want on the page.
And that might be
preferred by your users.
FILIP: Interesting.
That's good to know.
OK, so we have this now.
Now what about this bottom bar?
Do we want to--
WILL: Yeah, it's not
doing much right now.
FILIP: Should I
just make it black?
WILL: Black would be cool.
I mean, we're just
playing now anyway.
I mean--
FILIP: Yeah, yeah.
So I saw a bottom bar color.
So we can just do black.
WILL: But that's bottom app bar.
This is a tab bar.
FILIP: Ah, that's true.
OK.
So we need to set it--
I think we need to set
it somewhere around here,
BottomNavigationBar.
WILL: Were there no
fields inside theme data
that refer to bottom
navigation bar?
FILIP: I'm not sure.
I assume not.
So bottom-- no.
WILL: OK.
FILIP: So color?
Fixed color?
WILL: Hm.
FILIP: Hm.
The color of the selected
item on button navigation bar
is fixed.
WILL: Well it shouldn't be
broken in the first place.
So, ThemeData.primarycolor
is what
it's taking, which is why
it's yellow to read there.
And then if I don't know
where a color is coming
from in the widget because
theming is involved, I go back
to the inspector, and look up
the tree till I find a theme
data that encapsulates
it, and then
see this is clearly a
white or gray, like--
FILIP: Right.
So I just do the
whole thing here?
WILL: Mm-hmm.
FILIP: And then we have--
WILL: Probably this stack or
the bottom navigation tile
is the thing that
actually has a color.
And it may not
tell you in there,
which is OK, because we're just
going to keep going up the tree
until we find what
we're looking for.
FILIP: So should I go up?
WILL: Mm-hmm.
Great.
So that's the other tile.
That's the two tiles.
There's a text
tile, which must be
we're getting the information
for the text that's in there.
FILIP: So that's the builder.
WILL: Go past that Custom
Paint, because that's
the top thing I can see.
So it's a piece of material.
FILIP: Mm-hmm.
Transparency, though.
WILL: So we could find
out where material
with the type transparency
gets its color by default.
FILIP: OK.
WILL: That's my best guess.
FILIP: Let's do that.
WILL: There might be a
better way to do this,
and I just don't know.
FILIP: So do we--
ah.
WILL: So I do
Command-O, and that
lets me pull up the
class that I want to see.
Yeah.
And it's good to--
especially for material-- do
that, because material.dart
is also an umbrella header.
So if you end up trying to
go to the file material.dart,
you may end up in the one
that has no content for you.
FILIP: Right.
So we need a transparency--
OK.
And so where is this used?
Oh, many places.
Hey, it looks like
it's just transparent,
which is weird, right?
WILL: Yeah, so it returns
that instead of the other one
that has a background
color set on it.
FILIP: So maybe there's
something even like--
WILL: Maybe there's another
way that this is set, then.
FILIP: So do this again.
Constraint docs?
WILL: Oh, it looks like it's in
the-- was it in another stack?
FILIP: This?
WILL: Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
You still keep going up.
And then-- because you
see, it's all still
around just that area.
OK, now we've left it.
So whatever the last
thing you hit was before--
FILIP: This one.
WILL: --going up.
OK.
So that is the top
widget in this branch
of the tree that controls
the bottom navigation bar.
FILIP: This is really useful.
We're getting, like, how do
you debug things like this.
Oh, color-- FAFAFA, maybe.
WILL: Maybe.
"Fa-fa-fa."
FILIP: " Can I change it here?
No.
WILL: No, but we could then
search through the code base
to see where that is.
FILIP: But physical model
having color, isn't that weird?
WILL: Well, physical
model is one of the--
if I'm not mistaken, what
material is made out of.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
WILL: So since material is
the primitive of all views
that we have in the
material library,
this is the primitive of that.
FILIP: Right.
So I think this might be
what we are looking for.
WILL: OK, so the color
is being set somewhere.
FILIP: This is the color here.
That's for sure.
Hm.
WILL: But the problem is
if it's not part of the API
that we have access to
in bottom navigation
bar, that's not much use to us.
FILIP: Yeah.
Widget Animate Color?
Hm.
Widget Color.
Yeah.
All right, so where is this--
WILL: This might be a
Stack Overflow moment.
FILIP: Oh, really?
WILL: Yeah
FILIP: OK
WILL: Oh, did you
think I was teaching?
No.
FILIP: No, wait, so there's
the background color used here.
getBackgroundColor.
How do you get a
background color?
WILL: Oh--
FILIP: Material.
WILL: Return null.
FILIP: Theme.of context
cardColor, or canvasColor.
WILL: Only if that's
your type of material.
And ours is transparency.
FILIP: Well, but no,
this is coming from--
we're not coming
from the add bar.
I came here from the other one.
WILL: Oh, from bottom--
FILIP: Yeah.
Let's try either--
WILL: Yeah, let's play with
the other theme data values.
FILIP: Yeah, canvas or card.
OK.
Just before we go through
the whole cycle of things.
So, cardColor, Colors.
Yeah, I don't want this anymore.
Black.
WILL: Not cardColor,
which makes sense.
It's not like a card.
But it's kind of like a canvas.
FILIP: Canvas.
Ooh.
WILL: Yes.
FILIP: Yes.
WILL: That's it.
FILIP: Does it look good?
WILL: Well, the
one thing that we
might want to check
is, is the black, which
is kind of our text color,
accessible against the yellow?
Does it have a high
enough contrast ratio.
And so I do that by--
there is a website,
if you search for
it in Google.com,
just go contrast ratio.
FILIP: What the hell was that?
Contrast ratio.
WILL: I can't teach you
how to spell, Filip.
FILIP: Contrast ratio.
WILL: Yeah, and
then scroll down.
There's like-- there it is.
You know, I could
have remembered
that-- contrast.ratio.
So it doesn't matter
if you put one
in the background or the other.
It's just going to give you the
same number, because they're
related.
FILIP: And then black?
WILL: Yeah, I think you
can just type black,
and it understands it.
FILIP: 15.7.
WILL: That's great.
FILIP: That's great?
WILL: Yeah.
Just for fun, go to
white where black is.
FILIP: White.
WILL: Yeah.
So you see?
This is a mistake
that people make.
FILIP: I like it.
WILL: Yeah, very sad.
What you want is at
least 3, I think,
for large text, and
4.5 for small text,
is a good rule of thumb.
FILIP: OK, so we're good.
WILL: So we're good.
Just a good thing to check.
FILIP: So one thing
that we're not that
great with is black on black.
So maybe we can fix that.
Let's see.
[ELEVATOR MUSIC PLAYING]
So there was so long
odyssey of looking
at code and other
things, using the things
that we've shown you before.
We basically went
to the inspector
and saw that the text that we
were trying to get not black
is here, and that it's defined
in bottom navigation tile.
So we did bottom
navigation tile,
and we read the source until
Will figured out that it's
using the caption theme.
WILL: Yeah, it's
got a cool color
tween, which is a
kind of animation that
goes between two colors.
And it said that one
color is the color
that we've passed in
another place, which
ends up being the yellow.
And the other one
was the one that you
get from the text theme of the
main theme's caption style.
FILIP: That's true.
WILL: Which makes
sense, because it's
kind of like a caption for
the icon, or a caption for--
FILIP: Yes, yes.
WILL: --the bottom
navigation item.
FILIP: So--
[HOOTING]
--OK, let's go a couple of-- so
I just want to maybe make this
a little less--
this looks like it's selected,
and it's actually not selected.
WILL: Oh, yeah.
Try white with an opacity.
I think white 87.
FILIP: White 87?
WILL: You don't have to do that.
You can just-- we have
constants for some of them.
Like--
FILIP: White-- oh.
WILL: Oh, sorry.
Not 87.
Yeah, 54, try one of those.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's cool.
FILIP: I like it.
WILL: There's some
values in material design
that we use a lot.
And we have copies of them here.
And that's the alpha
of 54 on white.
FILIP: Right.
Cool.
So we have this.
So let's do something
about this one if we can.
WILL: The color of
that text there?
FILIP: I mean, I'm not
a huge fan of this,
and this, maybe, and
the text [INAUDIBLE]
WILL: The 810 comments
doesn't line up to anything.
And what does this button do?
FILIP: That opens
the web browser.
WILL: Hm.
Oh, OK.
FILIP: And there was like one of
the first Boring Show episodes
where we did this.
So we can definitely--
yeah, so what we
have here is main--
so it's a row.
WILL: It's a row.
FILIP: It's a row
of two children,
and it's spaced evenly.
WILL: Yeah.
FILIP: So we can do--
WILL: Start.
Let's try start.
FILIP: Start?
Interesting.
WILL: That'll bring the comments
all the way over to the left.
FILIP: Yes, but also this--
WILL: Too far to the left.
FILIP: But that's fine.
We can have padding.
WILL: Yeah, we'll add padding.
FILIP: But do we want the
other one on the right?
Like if I do a space
between, we have this.
Do we want this?
WILL: Not terrible.
[CHUCKLING]
I mean--
FILIP: Yeah, that's my bar.
WILL: One thing I worry about
is you want to make sure
that you have 48 by 48 for
the hit zone around anything
that's going to be touched.
And this one brings it pretty
close to the other one.
FILIP: Right.
WILL: It might make sense--
so if you tap on Comments,
does that do anything?
FILIP: No, but it should.
It should.
WILL: What do you want it to do?
FILIP: To maybe open
the comments of the--
because this one goes
to the source article,
as in your Hacker News, but
this one shows you the comment--
should show you.
We haven't implemented it yet.
WILL: Well, I was going
to say, I think I could--
if it were pinned to
it over here, or if--
OK.
FILIP: Yeah, it can also--
I'm not married to it
being this icon, right.
So it could say something.
Let's do Start.
WILL: Well, what
I think would be
perfect is if you could
tap on the title now
that it's selected, because
it kind of looks like a link,
and if that took you out there.
FILIP: Hm, yeah.
I mean, it's possible.
WILL: I don't know.
FILIP: But we're using
this expansion tile.
And let's see what
it can do for us.
Initially expanded-- yeah,
that's really much it.
I think it only has that.
WILL: Well, IRL, we could
wrap the text widget
inside a gesture
recognizer for tap.
And we might need
to then really note
if it's already in its
expanded state or not.
Well, it depends on what
we want the UX to be.
FILIP: Hm, I just
needed to check.
So--
WILL: That's cool.
FILIP: --trailing is the--
trailing is--
WILL: The expansion
into [INAUDIBLE]
FILIP: Right, right.
OK.
OK, so because of the
limited time, let's just--
WILL: Let's lose it,
and just align the 810.
FILIP: Yes.
So the whole thing here, we
don't need this, by the way.
So the whole row--
WILL: The whole row.
FILIP: --should
be a heading of--
WILL: Is that 16?
FILIP: Mm-hmm.
And it's probably symmetric.
Horizontal 16.
Sorry?
WILL: It's starting
to look good.
I like that layout already.
One thing that's not so
great is that the icon
is center-aligned to that text,
and it might make more sense
if it were baseline-aligned.
FILIP: Oh, so like
crossAxisAlignment, cross--
baseline?
WILL: Maybe.
If not, then the bottom one.
FILIP: What does it say?
crossAxisAlignment
is not baseline.
Oh, we need the text baseline.
WILL: Oh, well then
let's try just--
because we're lucky it's
aligned with the end.
No, because that-- is
that an icon button?
That looks bad with all
that padding around it.
FILIP: Yes.
WILL: Never mind.
It's fine the way it was before.
FILIP: Right.
Maybe we'll want to just give
it some space, like with a--
I sometimes do this if I'm lazy.
So like--
WILL: We all do that.
FILIP: 16.
WILL: Oh, that's much better.
Now I really feel like
I have enough room
kind of for my thumb.
FILIP: Right.
WILL: Or whatever.
Well, I mean, most of
the time you touch stuff
with your thumb.
Yeah.
FILIP: Yeah, all right.
So what else?
So I don't love the blue,
but maybe it's fine.
WILL: Well, I think
we need to admit
that, while we've had some
fun putting in the Owl thing
to see the big changes, now
might be the time to put them
to the values from
Fortnightly, which
would be probably more beautiful
and pleasing in the long run.
FILIP: Right.
So you want to do the--
WILL: To white.
FILIP: White.
Back to white.
WILL: Yeah.
So--
FILIP: So the primary
color would be just white.
WILL: Let's try it.
FILIP: Yeah.
WILL: Looking good.
WILL: And you know what?
I don't hate the black
tabs at the bottom, either.
FILIP: Mm-hmm.
Do you want to use a
different font, maybe,
and that would be our finishing
thing to do in this [INAUDIBLE]
WILL: Yeah, we
have a custom font.
FILIP: Yeah?
WILL: Google Fonts has
thousands of them for free.
FILIP: Fonts-- but you can
use any TrueType font, right,
or any webfont--
or basically, you don't
need to use Google Fonts is
what I'm saying.
WILL: Oh, right.
No, it's just good to
know that your font has
a proper license for the
use you're going to have.
FILIP: True.
And with Google
Fonts, you're covered?
WILL: It will tell
you the license,
and if I'm not mistaken, almost
all of them are OK for use.
FILIP: All right,
so what should we--
WILL: So usually
things are about type
have a serif font, like
Times New Roman or something
like that.
FILIP: And by the
way, we're not--
you're not reading a lot.
You're basically
reading just the title.
So maybe for this--
and maybe we can keep
the comments in--
WILL: --in a sans-serif, yeah.
I'm just talking
about headline text.
FILIP: Yes, the headline.
So the headline could be
something even like display.
So the categories, I think, is
like-- so serif is like this,
but display are
these weird, more--
WILL: Oh, those are fun.
FILIP: Yeah, those are more fun.
So maybe one of those?
WILL: Hm.
Something futuristic
if it's Hacker News.
FILIP: Oh, yeah, that's right.
WILL: We could go with
something monospace,
because it looks like code.
FILIP: True.
Something bold, maybe?
Like the Fortnightly.
I have-- where are they?
Fortnightly.
Oh, it's not bold.
WILL: Well, it's kind of bold.
FILIP: Right, yeah, it is.
OK.
So would you like--
should I start filtering?
WILL: Well, I don't know.
I'm no good at shopping.
Oh, that one's kind of cool.
FILIP: This one?
WILL: It's all futuristic-y.
FILIP: Not very
readable, though.
WILL: Not very readable.
FILIP: What about this one?
No, it's--
WILL: That looks
like a ransom note.
[CHUCKLING]
FILIP: That's true.
This one is very newsy.
Ugh, really?
WILL: I-- ah-- too code?
FILIP: I don't know.
WILL: Too retro?
FILIP: We can do that.
WILL: Do it.
You'll notice it.
FILIP: Yeah, all right.
So normally, I never
know how exactly
to work with this, but
basically I do the--
WILL: Move it down.
FILIP: Yeah.
And then it gives me a ZIP file.
And then there's the license,
which I don't understand.
And then there's the TTF font.
And then I just put it inside--
WILL: I like to make
a fonts directory
if I don't have one already.
FILIP: Yes.
Let me just make this.
So--
WILL: Sibling with lib.
FILIP: Right.
New Directory, Fonts.
And I'm just going to--
WILL: Drag it in.
FILIP: Drag it in.
[MAKING CLICKING SOUND EFFECT
WITH MOUTH]
Yes.
All right, and now we
need to go to pubspec.
Now I don't know how to add it.
WILL: It's a font.
FILIP: Right.
WILL: I think it
might be top level.
Yeah, it's good to look up.
FILIP: Ah, fun.
Font custom.
Custom fonts.
Flutter fonts.
I'm just going to do this.
So the family, we can actually--
so PressStart.
And it's going to be in
fonts/PressStart2P-Regular.ttf.
Right?
WILL: I think so.
FILIP: And so now we
need to close the app,
and rerun it again.
WILL: Yeah, because we're
bringing in a new file.
FILIP: Right.
And then just for
the title of that--
OK, let me-- while
it's launching.
WILL: Well, the great
thing is, we already
started modifying
the text theme.
FILIP: Right.
Oh, you want to do
it with a text theme?
I thought I would
just paste it onto it.
WILL: You can do that, too.
FILIP: Right.
But yeah, we can do--
that would be a
headline, I guess.
WILL: We should know, or we
will be looking for a while.
FILIP: True.
OK.
Wait until that's all done.
Go.
WILL: It sounds like
it's about to blast off.
FILIP: Yeah.
WILL: Now, I know you
call this the Boring Show,
but I've always
thought it was more
like a soothing sort of
show, like a homemaking show.
FILIP: Uh-huh.
WILL: Kind of like an inherited
model isn't just a great way
to pass information
through your widget tree,
it's also an elegant way to
implement material theming.
It's a good thing.
FILIP: Yeah.
It's [INAUDIBLE] All right, so
it looks like it's coming up.
OK.
Yep.
And now you were asking me--
how do we get this huge text?
WILL: So I think if we click
on text, and then look at its--
for default text style
and then its debug label,
that's what it is.
Subhead.
FILIP: Subhead.
Is it subhead?
Really?
WILL: Well, what do
you think a subhead is?
FILIP: I don't know.
[CHUCKLING]
OK, so subhead is new text
style with a font family of--
I forgot-- PressStart.
WILL: And if it
didn't yell at us--
FILIP: Whoa.
[CHUCKLING]
WILL: Well--
--you notice it.
I've definitely
noticed the change.
I bet everybody
at home has, too.
FILIP: Yes, yes.
No, I like it.
I like it.
Maybe I'll make it
a little less huge.
WILL: Yeah.
FILIP: Yeah, so maybe what--
WILL: 12.
FILIP: fontSize--
not fontWeight.
fontSize 12.
No.
Was it 12?
WILL: Since it's the theme, you
might have to do a hot restart.
FILIP: Right.
No
WILL: Did that get bigger?
FILIP: No, it's the same size.
I know what was happening.
WILL: Oh, it's new text.
FILIP: Right.
What does it not get--
oh, maybe it's
overridden by the thing.
But anyway, we don't have--
I think we don't have time
for another hunt for where
it's set up.
I think we've definitely
made it a more memorable app.
Thank you for your
service, Will.
WILL: My pleasure.
So I know we're out
of time for today.
We haven't gotten the
app where we want it.
It's certainly not in the
finished design state.
But we have discovered all
of the API in the places
that we need in order
to make some of our most
opinionated changes.
So maybe on your own,
or with a designer,
you can then go in and really
pick the font that you want,
really pick the
colors that you want.
And now you know how to
make it look that way.
FILIP: Yeah.
And thank you for being
with me on the show.
What we talked today about
is the Material.io site,
where you can get
inspiration for your app,
and how to architect
it in terms of design.
We also talked about
basically theming in general.
How to-- if you don't
know how to get--
like how does Flutter get
to say that this thing will
be, like, gray?
How do you do debug that
using the Flutter Inspector?
And then we also implemented
new fonts, and made--
I think the app looks way
better than it did before,
and it's definitely more custom.
WILL: Yeah.
And we definitely changed the
theme data values ourselves,
with copy width, and also by
making some of them explicit.
And so these will propagate
throughout the whole app.
FILIP: Yeah.
All right, so
thanks for watching,
and see you in the next episode.
WILL: Thanks.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]